madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal
le recueillement et la douleur à
tel-aviv des adolescents de leur famille
pour les funérailles de leurs camarades
qui se sont déroulées aujourd'hui après
l'attentât suicide de vendredi dernier
on l'appelait le pape de la bonté le
coran de boer mythe de jean xxiii exposé
place saint pierre devant des dizaines
de milliers de fidèles un voyage pour
l'éternité puisque jean xxiii sera
inhumé dans la basilique
c'est jeudi prochain que sera inauguré
le tgv méditerranée aux ans de lutte et
de concessions pour que le tracé la
construction de la ligne puisse aboutir
ses détracteurs craignaient qu'il ne
défigure la provence l'environnement a
été protégée au mieux les il ya des
perdants
et puis cinéma avec la sortie attendue
de la superproduction pearl harbor de
nombreux effets spéciaux de qualité pour
retracer la tacc japonaise qui a
entraîné les etats-unis dans la guerre
un film romanesque qui est déjà un très
gros succès en amérique
des centaines d'adolescents portant le
deuil se sont rassemblés au nord de
tel-aviv pour accompagner au cimetière
leurs amis leurs frères ces victimes du
massacre de vendredi dernier scène
déchirante de ses élèves qui font
l'expérience du deuil
un cortège de douleurs encadrés par les
hautes autorités de la ville et du
gouvernement qui s'était fait
représenter
le dernier bilan du massacre le plus
meurtrier depuis cinq ans et de 20
victimes et une centaine de blessés tous
des jeunes de 14 à 20 ans pour la
plupart issus de familles russes ayant
immigré en israël à nizar amiens
enlacés dans la douleur s'embrassant
dans les larmes désarroi d'adolescents
venus rendre hommage dans ce cimetière
de tel-aviv à deux de leurs amis deux
soeurs vendredi soir la mère de julia
saison et de vilhena 18 ans a essayé de
retenir ses filles à la maison par peur
des attentats mais elle voulait
absolument aller danser
pour moi c'est comme si j'avais perdu
une de mes propres filles jolies à venez
chez moi elle était toujours content
ces adolescents sont tous des filles et
fils d'immigrant arrivé il y a trois
quatre ou cinq plans de russie je ne
pensais pas que ce serait comme ça en
israël mais avec le temps je commence à
avoir peur et maintenant quand j'entends
des sirènes j'ai peur je pensais que ce
serait mieux ici qu'en russie la main
tant que j'enterre mes amis je comprends
qu'il n'ya pas de différence
quatorze fois aujourd'hui à tel aviv
les rabbins ont chanté le kaddish la
prière des morts aidé par de simples
gestes au deuil des mères
autour des familles des députés du parti
russophone partisans de représailles
contre les palestiniens
il faut une vengeance on ne peut pas
continuer comme ça il nous tue son qu'on
réagisse parce que la france et d'autres
pays dits civilisés sont contre nous et
nous accuse d'être les agresseurs mais
aujourd'hui dans ce cimetière le temps
politique était un peu suspendue pour
laisser place à l'émotion et en toute
fin d'après-midi le hamas a revendiqué
clairement l'attentât de tel aviv
information donnée à beyrouth par la
télévision du mouvement chiite du
hezbollah
presqu'au même moment le père du
kamikaze responsable du carnage devant
la discothèque son père s'exprimait son
fils c'est comme lui palestiniens
installés en jordanie
ils ignoraient tout des activités de
saïd âgé de 22 ans qui apparemment
toujours selon les dires de son père
n'aurait aucune appartenance politique
connue il semblerait que ce jeune homme
installé en cisjordanie depuis deux ans
était l'ami intime d'un des membres du
hamas mort dans un attentat suicide et
que son geste aurait été dicté par la
vengeance des propos qui n'engagent que
le père du kamikaze qui est sous le choc
mais dit-il fier de son fils
vingt-quatre heures après l'ultimatum
lancé par le gouvernement sharon à
yasser arafat en cisjordanie et à gaza
d' des signes de bonne volonté et si les
policiers palestiniennes n'ont pas
arrêté les chefs islamistes
ils déploient leurs forces pour empêcher
les attaques anti-israéliennes la
population quant à elle se prépare à une
riposte de l'armée
challans d'ailleurs une scène
inhabituelle à gaza la sécurité
palestinienne contrôler les véhicules la
proximité des positions israéliennes
erez le point de passage est fermée gaza
est bouclée personne ne rentre personne
ne sort les livraisons de carburants
sont suspendus c'est surtout cela qui
inquiète les gazant dans quelques jours
il n'y aura plus une goutte d'essence
dans les stations-services filmé ici
pour la première fois le comité
regroupant les 13 organisations de
l'intifada s'est réunie en fin de
matinée tous sont là les représentants
du fatah de yasser arafat dur hamas du
djihad du front populaire pour eux
accepté le cessez-le-feu se formule de
cette manière lorsque le président
arafat a donné l'ordre de cesser le feu
il était clair pour nous que c'était
dans le cadre d'un plan global destiné à
lutter contre le complot anti
palestinien de sharon une réunion
similaire s'est tenue à bethléem où
toutes les organisations décidé
d'interdire les tirs en direction de
guilo un quartier juif du sud de
jérusalem ce soir nous allons prendre
des mesures concrètes des forces
palestiniennes vont être déployés dans
les rues du secteur pour appliquer les
ordres du président arafat a priori des
signes plutôt positifs mais à jéricho
qu'il le peut quitter en raison du
bouclage
le principal négociateur palestinien est
inquiet au niveau de confiance entre
nous et les israéliens nuls et il
faudrait donc une tierce partie les
américains pour surveiller cela et
mettre en place un système de contrôle
sur le terrain sans cela tout va
s'effondrer en tout cas ce soir à
bethléem les forces palestiniennes ont
tenu parole
elles se sont déployés pour empêcher les
tirs sur jérusalem et en direct de
jérusalem charles enderlin avez-vous
confirmation ou non de cette information
qui nous est parvenu en fin d'après-midi
et veut quand une attaque ciblée
israélienne contre des objectifs du
hamas et du jihad islamique a priori
béatrice cette information est inexacte
au contraire la journée a été
extrêmement calme il n'y a pas eu un
seul blessé
il n'y a pas eu de tirs l'armée
israélienne a même pris le soin de
démentir une de ses propres informations
sur les tirs en direction d'une colonie
cela
cela n'a pas été le cas alors s'agit-il
d'une trêve d'un cessez-le-feu du calme
avant la tempête
il a encore trop tôt pour le savoir tout
cela est extrêmement fragile le moindre
incident risque à nouveau de faire
basculer la région
les diplomates sont au travail le
ministre des affaires étrangères
allemand joschka fischer mme attias soit
poursuit son séjour en israël il
rencontre yasser arafat
il doit rencontrer à rick sharon peut
être parviendra t'il au nom de l'union
européenne a négocié un véritable accord
merci salle en l1 puis pour clore ce
chapitre il faut savoir que la compagnie
air france a suspendu jusqu'à lundi ou
mardi ses vols à destination de tel aviv
par mesure de sécurité
une décision mal comprise par l'état
hébreu qui a ordonné l'ouverture d'une
enquête
cette mesure touche également delta air
lines qui a annulé ses vols pour la
journée de dimanche
en israël la france a expliqué que
l'attentât s'était déroulé tout près de
l'hôtel où font escale ses équipages
encore ce l'assassin présumé d'un
gendarme en 1988 qui n'est autre quand
je marie orsini a été arrêté et devrait
être déféré devant un juge
antiterroriste c'est l'analyse des adn
d'un des ses cheveux qui la cuisse
stéphane lissner un seul cheveu retrouvé
dans cette voiture il ya 13 ans voilà ce
qui a permis de confondre ange-marie
orsoni 7 bx blanche aurait servi le 8
mars 88 un commando du flnc pour
mitrailler la légion de gendarmerie
ajaccio ce jour là stéphane chariot 27
ans est en faction devant la caserne
touché par deux balles il s'écroule
avant de mourir quelques minutes plus
tard
à cette époque la sphère provoque une
grande émotion en corse charles pasqua
et jacques chirac alors premier ministre
font le déplacement pour la levée du
corps
l'enquêté est au point mort jusqu'en
septembre 98 au cours d'une opération de
police dans une cave près d'ajaccio
les enquêteurs retrouvent une clé de
voiture et prélève de l'adn il
correspond à celui du cheveu retrouvé
dans la bx ange-marie orsoni ancien
leader du mouvement nationaliste mpea a
été écroué jeudi soir il nie toute
participation aux moeurs
les magistrats eux ne sont pas au bout
de leurs peines pas d'aveux une affaire
vieille de 13 ans et une expertise adn
que les avocats sont bien décidés à
contester dans la somme victimes pendant
des semaines des inondations les travaux
d'endiguement nécessaires auraient été
sabotée en partie une brèche creusée
dans les sacs de sable résultera d'actes
de malveillance selon la préfecture
fort heureusement les dégâts ont été
rapidement réparée frédéric vion et
dominique maes c'est une digue longue de
plusieurs kilomètres de simples sacs de
sable mais qui suffisent depuis le
retrait partiel des eaux pour protéger
fontaine sur somme c'est ici que je dis
des vandales ont ouvert une brèche de 2
mètres de large
un geste criminel que les fontenois
n'arrive pas à comprendre c'est vrai
qu'on va y avoir une explication ces
gens qui ont fait ce genre de choses
nous expliquent pourquoi ils font ça
le niveau de l'eau à remonter assez
rapidement les gens se sont trouvés
paniquer sitôt qu'on a entendu parler
clos remonter les gens sont arrivés en
mairie en demandant un peu ce qui se
passe et ne comprennent pas et je vais
vous dire que nos opérations de secours
retirer les parpaings et hautes
on a stoppé tout tout de suite parce
qu'on ne comprenait pas exactement ce
qui se passait
c'est pourtant essentiellement grâce à
ces digues que pour la première fois
depuis dix semaines les habitants de
fontaine ont enfin les pieds hors de
l'eau sur les murs les traces de
l'inondation sont encore fraîches mais
depuis hier les propriétaires des toutes
dernières maisons les plus proches de la
rivière peuvent rentrer chez eux à pied
sec et constater l'étendue des dégâts
j'espère que c'est la première et mes
petits-enfants non plus au dehors le
travail des secours est encore loin
d'être terminé le canal de fontaine est
rentré dans son lit mais il s'en faut de
peu pour qu'il ne déborde à nouveau les
trois pontes tournent jour et nuit
850 mètres cubes heures et deux de 240 p
fumeurs et pompent l'eau du canal vers
la rivière aux sommes qui se trouve à
une distance d'environ
650 m mardi 70 bénévoles de la direction
de l'équipement viendront aider l'armée
dans ses travaux de régulation de la
somme des travaux lourds qui
nécessiteront une fois encore le
dynamitage de certains ponts dans les
ardennes l'évacuation de tout un village
pour permettre aux artificiers de
neutraliser quelques 170 tonnes le début
de la première guerre mondiale
découvert au début de l'année
contrairement à vimy où quatre de ces
obus n'est toxique l'opération doit
durer au total neuf jours elle a été
préparée de longue date la ligne sncf
paris charleville mézières sera
fortement perturbé les trains ne
circuleront aux heures de grande
affluence
deux escadrons de gendarmerie pendant
cercle et le village jour et nuit pour
éviter tout pillage
ce sera donc jeudi prochain que sera une
gré la ligne tgv méditerranée accessible
aux voyageurs à partir du 10 juin est
lancée que le tracé la construction de
cette voie express a suscité de nombreux
combats y débat un projet qui a provoqué
une levée de boucliers à travers toute
la provence qui craignaient d'être
défiguré après onze ans de lutte mais
aussi en concertation la sncf va
finalement que construire cette ligne
dans certains obligatoirement ont dit
faire les frais yannick aroussi benoît
jourdain depuis le début des essais sur
la nouvelle ligne tgv la vie de gilles
berhault rubin a légèrement changé
fini le havre de paix dans la campagne
provençale là vous avez un débat ferai
pas
une centaine de riverains du tracé
gilbert orjubin a participé en vain à la
lutte contre la construction de la ligne
on défend nos intérêts on ne peut pas le
cacher et on n'est pas dans nos intérêts
en défense aussi
c'est quand même une sacrée valeur et le
projet connu la provence se mobilisent
comme un seul homme manifestation gare
envahi frein bloqué une opposition au
choix d'une ligne nouvelle dans une
région riche peuplé qui veut préserver
son environnement et qui veut surtout
ouvrir une discussion avec la sncf au
début on arrive avec des plans qui
centaine qui peut l'ammoniac c'est pas
ça qui faisait passer le projet il
valait mieux et c'est ce qu'on a fait
après dire qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
pour que ce projet soit intégrée dans
les pays qu'on traverse qu'est ce que
vous souhaiteriez qu'on y met
après concertation après enquête
publique l'un des plus grands chantiers
de la fin du xxème siècle commence la
balafre comme l'appellent les opposants
se dessine en terre de provence entre
pression des écologistes et rivalités
des élus locaux le tracé devient sinueux
traverse quatre fois le ron et trois
fois la durance il ne coïncident qu'à
20% avec le tracé initial les opposants
obtiennent des tunnels supplémentaire le
passage souterrain près de l'hôpital
d'avignon la sncf reboise et en semences
c'est à lui pris des travaux 25
milliards de francs
un coup km trois fois plus élevé que
pour la ligne lyon-paris
les chiffres ont montré qu'ils voulaient
faire une ligne deux fois moins chère
que celle qu'ils ont faim qui voulait
faire une ligne super au rabais eh bien
disons que grâce à la pression pour
protéger l'environnement ils ont
notamment réussi à la faire - aura
baissé pour ça qu'aujourd'hui on peut
trouver qu'elle n'est pas aussi
catastrophique que ce qui était prévu
par la ssr ont tous les jeunes qui ont
été créés et exproprié jeu park grâce
aux associations ont quand même été
analysée correctement
je passe c'est parti
forts de notre passion marseille paris
en trois heures
les écologistes auraient volontiers
perdu 10 minutes par ci par là pour
faire circuler des tgv pendulaires sur
les voies existantes selon la tradition
jacques chirac et son épouse an passé le
week end au fort de brégançon ce matin
sous un ciel de mistral le couple
présidentiel assister à la messe de
pentecôte
accueilli par un groupe folklorique
habituel ban foule pour le chef de
l'état et bernadette chirac est qui s'y
sont donc prêtés volontiers on
l'appelait le pape de la bonté jean
xxiii disparu il y à 38 ans était
célébrée en pleine lumière aujourd'hui à
rome quelques trente mille fidèles ont
pu se recueillir devant le corps embaumé
de ce pape qui trouvera pour l'éternité
refuge à l'intérieur de la basilique
jérôme benest demi que bernard ont
rencontré le préparateur du corps du
pape
il rend le silence pour que l'on ne
parle pas de miracle c'est la
béatification de jean xxiii en septembre
dernier qui a permis la procession
d'aujourd'hui en effet selon le rite
catholique seuls les bienheureux peuvent
être livrés à la vénération des fidèles
à condition d'être présentable pendant
38 ans jean xxiii avait reposé dans
cette crypte du vatican où jean paul ii
se recueillaient régulièrement en
janvier une reconnaissance canonique
montre que sa dépouille est très bien
conservé entre temps elle a été
recouverte d'une couche de cire
il bouleversé de voir au bout de 38 ans
le visage est intacte et je crois que la
science ne pourra jamais expliquer ce
phénomène
dès qu'il avait appris sa maladie un
cancer de l'estomac
jean xxiii avait donné des instructions
pour que son corps soit bien conservé
quelques heures après sa mort à la
pentecôte 2009 163 10 litres d'un savant
cocktail de fixateur son père fusé dans
les veines et dans l'abdomen de jean
xxiii une préparation dont un seul homme
connaît le secret puisqu'il en fut
l'auteur le professeur goglia qui n'est
pas étonné que son traitement est réussi
suivant une règle les 6 et rigoureuse et
alors rien à voir avec un miracle non
non non étrange pentecôte qui associe
les deux papes les plus populaires du
20ème siècle jean xxiii sera désormais
visible dans la basilique vaticane sous
l'autel de saint jérôme
c'est ainsi que le pape jean paul ii
veut perpétuer la vénération des fidèles
pour jean xxiii qui fut et qui reste un
modèle pour karol wojtyla on n'est pas
la crémation du roi et de la reine
assassiné il ya 24 heures par le prince
héritier selon la version officielle
même si depuis ce matin d'autres
hypothèses sont avancées celle de
l'accident par exemple difficile a
argumenté une histoire à dormir debout
selon les népalais qui n'appelle donc
pas la colère du peuple selon les rites
hindous les monarques ont été incinérés
sur les rives du fleuve sacré bague
mattia katmandou c'est l'un des parents
du roi qui est mis le feu au bûcher
alors qu'un orchestre jouer l'hymne
national 55 août de feu ont été tirés
des dizaines de milliers de népalais ont
assisté à cette crémation des files
d'attentes se sont formées toute la
journée pour la signature du livre de
condoléances
il ya tout juste vingt ans les
occidentaux découvrent l les premiers
cas de sida sans pouvoir imaginer à
l'époque la fulgurante épidémie qui
allait ravager la planète
continuant de toucher des milliers de
personnes aujourd'hui encore faute de
prévention est précisément c'est bien de
prévention qu'il est question en ce
moment ou plus
d'absence de prévention grande bretagne
vous en parlions hier comme en france le
sida a cessé de faire peur ou du mois
les pratiques à risque ont repris ce qui
inquiète associations et médecins et guy
leroy président gilbert une crème
solaire protectrice et les une crème
solaire très hydratante des préservatifs
c'est très étroit copie qui partent en
vacances nous sommes en 1986 c'est la
première campagne de prévention
française un sentiment d'injustice
d'autres suivront chaque année pour
tenter de faire face ou au moins de
ralentir une épidémie et la progression
exponentielle jusqu'en 1994
à cette date le nombre de cas de sida
commence à baisser
mais signe inquiétant depuis trois ans
cette diminution s'est considérablement
ralenti c'est l'effet trithérapie grâce
aux progrès de la science
on meurt beaucoup moins du sida et donc
on s'en protège moi dans ce bar parisien
les affiches de prévention sont relégués
au fond de la salle
les clients se sentent de moins en moins
concernés
là vous savez ils ont ils ont bu 2006
coca qu'on l'a fait et on dans un
endroit quelques colons dans un lieu
d'être on les prenne un peu plaisir et
ben voilà les mots et jules ferry
usage du préservatif est en train de se
perdre
des études récentes le prouve on a un
suivi des maladies sexuellement
transmissibles et en fait on a eu plein
banque est de 90 à 2001 qui ont montré
une augmentation des mst notamment
syphilis les gonococcies aussi de
manière totalement alarmante et c'est
vrai que ça c'était des signes avant
coureurs il y a dix ans les associations
se battait pour imposer la réalité du
sida aujourd'hui elles luttent contre
l'illusion que l'épidémie est terminée
cette semaine marquée par la polémique
autour des rave parties dans les rangs
politiques et notamment chez socialistes
ils ne sont pas tous d'accord pour qu'on
règlement de ces manifestations
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs daniel vaillant
le ministre de l'intérieur justifie
l'idée d'un contrôle de ces
rassemblements spontanés
joël bruandet et philippe hernandes ont
assisté la nuit dernière à une rave
party particulièrement organisé pour
éviter d'alimenter le débat
depuis dix jours les amateurs de règles
sont sous surveillance
les sénateurs ont adopté un amendement
qui les oblige à déclarer en préfecture
tout rassemblement rater cette nuit un
peu partout en france
les rêveurs se sont retrouvés par
téléphone comme d'habitude les
organisateurs de la free party que nous
avons suivi tenait à faire passer le
message pas de débordements résultat sur
les aires d'autoroutes qui sert de lieu
de rendez vous les rêveurs comme seb
présentent leurs meilleurs profils non
honnêtement nous on est des gens
civilisés on essaie d'orange est de plus
en plus ces gens passer le message
racheter des calmes et racheté débouté
par faire et petit à petit bain
ce mode immeuble du sein les choses vont
changer
nous sommes en pleine campagne à
quelques kilomètres de dreux les rares
gendarmes présents sur place ne se sont
pas opposés à la répartie 2 heures du
matin deux mille personnes commencent à
danser
ce qui n'empêche pas les considérations
politiques
lisa
contrairement à certaines free party le
terrain utilisé a cette fois été nettoyé
et dans la bonne humeur
cette hausse est certes la drogue est
présente mais rodolphe un des
organisateurs refusent l'éternel procès
qui est fait au mouvement techno on
travaille tous on met tous un petit peu
d'argent et et on en arrive à ça mais
c'est vrai que c'est pas la drogue qui
paye tout ça donc ça c'est vraiment
important et la drogue il y en a partout
il y en a dans les boîtes
il ya des gens qui payent sans bal le
samedi soir mercredi une délégation de
rêveurs devrait être reçue à l'assemblée
nationale en attendant d'engager un vrai
dialogue avec les pouvoirs publics
arlette laguiller sera donc bien
candidate à l'élection présidentielle
comme à son habitude comme on pouvait
s'y attendre
la porte parole de lutte ouvrière a
parlé de l'urgence de la manifestation à
venir contre les licenciements le 9 juin
prochain une charge contre les
entreprises les patrons les actionnaires
et le gouvernement
reportage et thierry clopeau et marie
pierre cassignard à la fête de lutte
ouvrière la tête de turc
c'est lionel jospin et son gouvernement
pour les militants la gauche
gouvernementale fait une politique de
droite
cela lui a coûté cher aux dernières
municipales sur l'échiquier politique
arlette laguiller a désormais une vraie
représentativité et le premier ministre
est en ligne de mire ou lyonnais j'ose
pas se dit de gauche mais ils mènent la
même politique que la droite en faveur
des intérêts du patronat et je dirais
qu'aujourd'hui face à cette affaire des
licenciements c'est encore plus visible
lutte ouvrière n'appellera pas à voter
pour le candidat de gauche au deuxième
tour de la présidentielle résultat les
socialistes accusent l'extrême gauche de
faire le jeu de la droite
pour les militants socialistes et
communistes se sont coupés de leur
électorat populaire
ils payent la note quand il ya eu
des annonces de licenciements récemment
c'est pas moi qui ai dit qu'il pouvait
rien c'est jospin qui a dit qu'il
pouvait rien là bas nous on pense qu'il
faudrait quelque chose justement
jusqu'en 2002 en est la guye et compte
bien occuper pleinement le terrain
politique et sociale elle sera la tête
de la grande manifestation samedi
prochain à paris pour l'interdiction des
licenciements une façon comme une autre
d'accentuer le rapport de force avec la
majorité plurielle quelques jours avant
le vote à l'assemblée du projet de loi
de modernisation sociale dans une
semaine tout juste ce sera la veillée
d'armes pour les candidats au bac il se
rend plus de 600 31000 cette année à
plancher sur les premières épreuves de
philo d'ores et déjà certaines options
des bac techno ont commencé depuis une
quinzaine de jours
les 3000 lycées soit 95 % des
établissements en france se transforme
petit à petit en centres d'examen un
aménagement méticuleux auquel ont
assisté et les nuggets frédéric forte
dans un lycée de dijon comme un trésor
bien gardés dans un lieu tenu secret les
sujets du bac
placé par discipline par date des
preuves car le jour j pas de droit à
l'erreur
c'est très très organisés au moment des
épreuves donné bon sujet au bon moment
le bon sujet les bonnes conditions pour
le traiter dans l'organisation du bac
rien n'est laissé au hasard chaque salle
est réparée en vue de l'examen des
quantités de papier brouillon copies
sont nécessaires c'est aussi pour les
épreuves pratiques du bac professionnel
ou technologique du matériel
indispensable pour traiter tel ou tel
sujet au lycée hippolyte-fontaine 990
candidats viennent chercher leur
convocation cette année pour passer le
bac ou plutôt à bach
général professionnel ou technologique
il existe officiellement aujourd'hui 57
bacs différents avec pour chacun des
options au choix
votre spécialité d'options a augmenté
vous prenez le bac s par exemple chez
nous vous pouvez le passé avec quatre
spécialités différentes
les parcours sont très individualisé des
candidats qu'ils prennent deux options
facultatives etc
c'est ça qui complexifie l'ensemble
véritable casse tête
la répartition des sages mais il faut
aussi trouver des surveillants pour
chaque épreuve prévoir aussi les
correcteurs pour les écrits des
examinateurs pour les oraux puis
certains sont convoqués pour les créer
d'autres pour les créer l'orage d'autres
pour pour tous et nous c'est toujours
tout ah bon plus des trois quarts des
professeurs du lycée hippolyte fontaine
seront réquisitionnés pour le bac à
partir du 11 juin
impossible dans ces conditions de
maintenir les cours pour les 300 élèves
de seconde
ils seront donc suspendus pendant deux
semaines et censé venir le 23 juin je
pense pas qu'ils vont nous qui va
revenir
selon le bak filtrées par un candidat
c'est entre 262 et 473 francs à la
collectivité des chiffres officiels qui
tiennent compte des fournitures ou des
corrections n'est pas des milliers
d'heures de cours perdues par les élèves
de seconde
ni des milliers d'heures de travail
consacrée dans chaque centre d'examen à
organiser le baccalauréat
on connaît les difficultés de la vie au
quotidien pour les patients touchés par
la maladie d'alzheimer afin de leur
donner davantage d'autonomie surtout de
les sortir de leur cadre habituel
cette expérience originale qui
consistera en une douzaine de malades au
bord de la mer laurence de cherves et
philippe quéron geovanni parlait cinq
langues
aujourd'hui il a du mal à aligner
quelques mots il y à 7 ans il a ressenti
les premiers troubles de la maladie
d'alzheimer
perte de mémoire de la notion d'espacé
de temps depuis six mois plus question
pour lui de vivre dans sa propre maison
auprès de sa femme nicole away
55 soit à 72 ans qui devraient être
retraités actifs
c'est quelque chose terrible et lord jim
holt même la femme auprès de moi parce
que sans ça j'aurais peur s'y tiendrait
pas le coup
voilà l'angoissent intérieur des malades
s'exprime surtout à travers le corps
le sport est un moyen de canaliser
l'énergie dont certains débordent
à l'initiative de leur médecin certains
malades vont donc partir quatre jours à
la mer au parc de marquenterre reprendre
contact avec la nature dans une nature
qui a une atmosphère apaisante comme
celle des oiseaux les envol d'oiseaux
les roseaux l'eau la mer et ils vont
retrouver des souvenirs d'anciens l'eau
l'élément qui leur rappelle leur enfance
eux qui ont souvent occultée plusieurs
dizaines d'années de leur vie nichols et
qu'elle a la chance que son mari la
reconnaisse l attend beaucoup de ce
voyage auquel elle participe avec un peu
un test pour voir peut-être je me fais
peut-être des illusions mais je me dis
assume deux voyages peut-être que
l'année prochaine je pourrai de
l'emmener quatre singes ou en moi aussi
en voyage si ça se passe bien
une lueur d'espoir pour ce couple brisé
par la maladie et si lui oublie les
détails du voyage le plaisir de se
retrouver restera lui intact
l'actualité sportive avec d'abord du
football de meilleurs jours pour
l'équipe de france qui en corée du sud a
battu le mexique 4 à 0 en se qualifiant
ainsi pour les demi finales de la coupe
des confédérations les tricolores qui
avaient pour l'occasion retrouver leurs
titulaires et qui du coup en effacer
l'affront subi vendredi dernier contre
l'australie
parmi les quatre buts de son signée éric
carrière les deux autres sylvain wiltord
des robert pirès roland garros avec au
terme d'un match époustouflant la
victoire de gustavo kuerten qui a sauvé
une balle de match face à l'américain
michael russell en revanche les français
n'ont pas tenu le cap
nicolas coutelot a été éliminé par
l'australien
artus et sandrine testud qui jouent en
8e de finale déjà une belle performance
pour la joueuse française
elle n'a pas su résister à la numéro un
martine en guise reportage christelle
bertrand nathalie gallet cqr thème côté
coeur comme celui qu'il dessine sur le
pur le chouchou du public s'est fait
peur face à un inconnu en plus russell
gagne 2,7 sans complexe et en souplesse
in extremis le double vainqueur de
roland garros et tenant du titre sauvait
même une balle de match
ensuite kuerten prend les choses en main
michael russell sort des qualifications
c'est déjà ce septième match du tournoi
alors forcément il a du mal à résister
aux coups de boutoir du brésilien
verte n s'impose en cinq sets en quart
de finale contre kafelnikov boga aura
encore une fois bien besoin du public
testud aurait pu elle ya cru mais pour
la 15e fois martina hingis remporte le
duel après 25 minutes de match et la
perte du premier set 6-1 la française se
décrispe et bouscule la numéro un
mondiale jusqu'à égaliser mais voilà
celle qui n'a jamais gagné roland garros
aimerait bien enfin que cette année soit
la bonne martina hingis accélère et
s'adjuge le troisième set
il n'y a plus de française dans le
tournoi mais une italienne sur la route
de martin hines la feria de nîmes avec
dans les arènes l'une des stars
montantes de la tauromachie le benjamin
sébastien castella qui n'a que 19 ans il
fait déjà preuve d'un courage et d'un
flegme peu courant une carrière à suivre
avec grande attention car une comédie
parce qu'elle pense
l'instant est sacrée pendant que
sébastien s'habille les madones baisse
leurs lourdes paupières dans un silence
religieux
la veste passé le torero est prêt
le mail et vierge à la faute au sol n'y
a pas de prière n'est pas croyant
c'est bien sûr mais je fais pas de prix
sébastien castella est un garçon sans
effusion il y a trois ans à peine il
quitte sa famille ses amis son école et
son pays pour apprendre la tauromachie
avec sa gueule d'ange aux allure d'icône
sévillanes sébastien revient au pays en
torero accompli
c'est un croisement entre nous pour les
uns des stands de rue alors quand à ma
main aux parents qui sont ici veut
produire
c est très calme
avec castella tout commence par un long
travail à la caf ou le ton est donné
élégant courageux ils cherchent le
taureau le frôle le provoque avec un
flegme impressionnant mais aujourd'hui
sébastien a eu très chaud
nous sentons souvent pieds nus le jeune
biterrois a gagné bien plus qu'une
oreille l'estiment de toute une reine
qui a trouvé son nouveau la journée du
vélo c'est dimanche apparaît dans
d'autres villes de france forcément une
bonne idée tout faire pour réduire les
voitures dans la capitale notamment à
l'initiative de la mairie de paris un
cortège de cyclistes a sillonné la ville
et pour ceux qui n'avaient pas de vélo
500 bicyclettes ont été mises
gracieusement à leur disposition
la circulation automobile a été
interdite sur les berges de la seine une
opération qui rencontre un franc succès
cinéma avec la sortie d'une
superproduction pour la qualité de ses
effets spéciaux il s'agit de pearl
harbor qui entraîna l'amérique dans la
guerre un succès retentissant déjà aux
états unis pour une fresque romantique
sur fond de guerre tous les ingrédients
y sont y compris un marketing très
judicieux pour lancer le film
marie-jo joie
le 7 décembre 1941 c'est un dimanche
matin paisible à cole harbour
les soldats de la base navale américaine
finisseur petit déjeuner lorsque soudain
surgit de nulle part
27 bombardier japonais vont anéantir en
deux heures une grande partie de la
flotte américaine du pacifique
un jour marqué du sceau de la famille
ira roosevelt le jour de l'entrée en
guerre des etats-unis sur l'arbre c'est
aussi un fait historique récupéré par
disney pour redorer un blason terni pour
que pearl harbour soit à disney ce que
titanic a été à la fox aux commandes
jerry bruckheimer le producteur
superstar des grosses productions
américaines
ajoutez à cela la bouleversante histoire
de deux jeunes pilotes amoureux de la
même infirmière
voici un cocktail dans la grande
tradition de lille ou lyon
quant à l'attaqué elle même 40 minutes
de combats la reconstitution de plus
proche de la réalité très peu d'effets
spéciaux numériques
contrairement aux films actuels je
voulais qu'on fasse sauter devrait
navire l'us navy nous en avait pressé
pour le tournage ce que j'avais repéré
moi-même à quand j'ai demandé si je
pouvais les faire sauter ils ont d'abord
dit non leur ai dit s'il vous plaît
c'est pour un grand film et ils ont
donné leur accord
toujours dans un souci de crédibilité
les survivants de l'attaqué japonaise
s'était longuement consulté pendant le
tournage à hawaï
la plupart d'entre eux ne se sont jamais
confié il n'en avait jamais parlé avant
qu'on commence à les interroger sur
l'événement pendant 60 ans ils ont gardé
le secret même leurs enfants ne savait
rien de ce qu'ils avaient enduré leurs
parents avant qu'on fasse les recherches
pour ce film alors pearl harbor un
nouveau phénomène titanic
sans doute mais aussi une grande fresque
digne de celle des années 40
romantique à souhait préparez donc vos
mouchoirs est la ferté alais que chaque
année ce meeting aérien qui met en
compétition pour le plaisir de tous une
centaine d'avions anciens les appareils
légendaire datant du début du siècle
jusqu'aux mirage 2000 qui ont paradé
donc dans le ciel la patrouille de
france aux côtés de fanatiques de
l'aviation comme cette passionnée de
voltige aérienne
et des dizaines de milliers de
spectateurs les yeux levés vers le ciel
c'est la fin de ce journal j'en appelle
le principal titre le recueillement et
la douleur à tel-aviv des adolescents et
de leurs familles pour les funérailles
de leurs camarades qui se sont déroulées
aujourd'hui après l'attentât suicide de
vendredi dernier dans un instant la
météo nathalie rihouet 20h50 urgence
erreur cinq le dernier journal jean
claude renoult demain 7h dans les 4
vérités gérard morin recevra jacques
maillard secrétaire national du rpf
trésor le journal gérard holtz à 20 ans
vous retrouverez benoît duquesne je vous
remercie de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée ce contenu